a hunger strike happening right now
inside a state prison thanks for joining
us here at six o'clock I'm David Schantz
I'm Denise Valdez this is just the
latest in fact in a series of problems
at the Department of Corrections that
the eight news now investigators have
exposed Vanessa Murphy here with what's
unfolding Vanessa Denise and David
inmates and workers have been trying to
sound the alarm for months basic needs
like Medical Care many times just aren't
being addressed now as things have come
to a head some inmates are protesting by
refusing to eat inmates at Ely state
prison now on that hunger strike the
Department of Corrections confirming
this in a press release after we first
reported it this afternoon stating
initially 39 inmates refused to eat
starting on December 1st but now five
days later that number has dropped to 27
although it fluctuates while the
department claims the hunger strike is
mainly over food portions advocacy group
returns strong tells us it's about many
different issues and simply Humane
treatment
every single person deserves to have
their basic needs met and I also think
that the punishment is incarceration the
punishment is not torture it is not a
lack of food it is not a lack of ability
to shower
the Maximum Security Prison is about a
four hour drive north of Las Vegas the
department says it's working to resolve
the matter and in me two are
participating in the Hunger Strike are
being monitored for weight and other
health factors back to you